And the answer here is the last two.
The question of is a program a virus
is a question about the program's
behavior as I've defined it.
Also, some programs are viruses and
some aren't, so
this can't be decided in general.
We can look for specific viruses and we
can monitor the behavior of programs for
suspicious activity.
Doing this is a billion dollar industry.
But we're never going to get
an all purpose virus detector.
Nor am I ever going to be able
to write the perfect test code
to see if the Turing machine that
you programmed to decide balance
strings actually works.
I can write test cases,
and detect common errors.
But I could never decide
completely whether your programs
are right or wrong.
On the other hand,
I can write a program to test whether
your reduction of HTM to the language
of Turing machines that accept
nothing is decidable, I simply reject.
Remember that no such reduction can
exist, because HTM is recognizable, and
ETM is corecognizable.
And lastly, this question about
whether a program will halt
in 10 to the 200 steps is decidable.
I just run the program for
up to that many steps.
Of course that number is so large
that in practice, even on the fastest
computers, the heat death of
the universe will have occurred by then.
But nevertheless,
the question is decidable.
The reason Rice's theorem doesn't
apply here is because this question
is about machines, not about languages.
The purpose of this quiz is not
to tell you that undecidability
is a concept with no
practical implications.
Rather, it is to help you to see
what it does and does not tell us.
Just because a problem is decidable
doesn't mean that it's tractable, or
practical to solve.
Also, just because a question
is undecidable in general,
doesn't mean that we can't write
programs to tackle specific cases,
as we do everyday with malware
detection and software testing.
It does however say that we should not
expect an all-purpose solution, and
any attempt to achieve that
end is doomed to fail.